[Music]
alright 13 minutes at 15 I say we need
sign-in hello I'm sorry I'm late that'll
never happen again okay welcome back to
another year this illustrious
institution as you know being at a
historically black college and
university it's a lot like being
surrounded by our family I should say
welcome home
let's get started with rolls shall we um
some on Fisk nashville tennessee music
management major by the way 30 dry balls
xxx anyone ladies free until 11:00 but
you know doors open at all that's enough
um do we have Jeanette Spellman here I'm
from Atlanta Georgia
I know some of you may not recognize me
but over the break I decided to cut my
hair so now you know I'm team natural oh
my god I love your texture what do you
put in it girl
I use a growth oil coconut styler and I
use the blueberry Paul made for my edges
Martha's family okay
no more open the class
um you're late what's your name McKenzie
Howard but I go by mecha he goes your
intro I'm a fashion major with a minor
in marketing and I'm from DC oh and
something about me
oh I modeled in New York Fashion Week
recently okay mecha please put your
phone away who we have next so you have
a Michael Dillard my name is Michael X
Dillard is my slave name
[Music]
X is a good strong last name just build
X just X see it okay quick quick and we
have all mister cooking
welcome back good to see you again we're
gonna get through it this time
hey professor Hamza alright so as you
know the syllabus reads that we start at
chapter 11 because I know everybody got
the syllabus read it so what's going to
happen is when I have a test every week
I pay per week keep those skills sharp
let's begin any questions
good I don't like questions let's go